there's a rumor about a bitcoin bug that
is circulating on the internet and this
is the most idiotic thing i have ever
seen and here's the post from at bitcoin
planner a pretty significant bitcoin bug
has been discovered described as a y2k
style bug in that satoshi didn't plan
for enough digits in the block height
for those who are more technical the max
height is a 32-bit unsigned integer
which means max height is 2
32 minus 1 not enough what is going on
can people not do math i'm not albert
einstein but i know that i can read the
comments and in the comments it says
that is not 81 years no ladies and
gentlemen it's 81 000 years literally
bad math leading to bitcoin fud all that
fud that fear uncertainty and doubt
making people actually think that there
is a y2k bug in the code now of course
y2k was fake and this bitcoin bug is
fake as well 81 000 years is not
something that you i or anyone else is
gonna have to worry about and if you are
bad at math maybe you should stop
spreading bitcoin rumors because
ultimately satoshi nakamoto created what
has become a trillion dollar asset it's
beautifully designed it's operating
exactly as it was designed bitcoin is
beautiful bitcoin is good for business
and bitcoin doesn't have any bugs